banker this week uh new york's defensive
coordinator suggested that the rodale is
not a
dynamic playmaker do you feel like he
showed otherwise tonight he said that
jesus
that's next question not a dynamic
football player let's go down the
sideline on the one hand
pretty dynamic
wait
here's the question so what did he say i
couldn't hear the question exactly the
question was that greg williams said
last week that odell beckham jr isn't a
dynamic football player
what's your end and that so that was
baker mayfield's response to it i love
it and look greg williams was just
saying and doing greg williams things
and did he not realize that odell
beckham jr would be extra motivated to
have the night that he had and guys it
was quite a night for the cleveland
browns it wasn't exactly the most
exciting game to watch and i give the
jets credit for not giving up it could
have been a miami dolphin-style blowout
last night they hung in there and even
in the fourth quarter when all hope was
lost le'veon bell was still running hard
peter but the cleveland browns went a
long way toward redeeming themselves for
that blowout loss at home nine days ago
with what they did to the jets on monday
night
i'm going to take a slight left turn and
just say
will there ever be a worse football
season
in new jersey
ever
than 2019.
look at the fate of the jets and the
giants i mean it's not quite
dolphin-esque but it's going down that
road and uh this could really really get
ugly uh just like i i mean mike i kind
of look at the jets right now and i say
look
you know the sam darnold thing is an
absolute total
fluke thing
but this is this just shows
what happens in my opinion a
when you
uh basically don't have a really good
backup quarterback and there aren't that
many of them but at least like if you're
the saints
you've got hope right now you've got
hope that teddy bridgewater and taysom
hill can hold it down for the next five
or six weeks but do you really have any
of that hope if you're the jets
well they yeah they're no they're not
going to have any hope now especially
without the backup quarterback who was a
decent option and trevor simeon and then
him getting hurt you know which we'll
see i mean i thought that was nasty and
going to be really bad there for a
second uh we'll see what the final
report is but i'm with you peter i mean
the giants it doesn't look like they're
going to turn things around and the jets
are certainly dug themselves in a hole
uh but not having sam darnold not having
cj mosley are certainly big blows to
that football team let alone they lost
quincy and nunes last week so they're
reeling there's no question about that
but the story of last night still was oh
a motivated browns team trying to get
back on track and really
trying to i feel like give it to greg
williams a little bit i feel like baker
mayfield wanted to give it to greg
williams we know o'dell wanted to give
it to greg williams we know freddie
kitchens wanted to give it to greg
williams and you know who else i feel
like miles garrett wanted to be like hey
look i have more than one pass rush move
now and look at me getting oh i'm
leading the nfl in sacks after the first
two weeks and i'm dominating i felt like
it was a motivated football team not
their best game i think we're ever going
to see them play but certainly showed us
some glimmer of just how explosive and
fun they can be to watch and it's a good
start for cleveland just to get off the
schneid and get a win
and and guys it really was a glimmer
right because they should have won that
game 45-3 not 23-3 and that odell
beckham jr spectacular catch on the
first drive you've got to turn that into
a touchdown right you've got to get
touchdowns instead of field goals when
it was six nothing it should have been
14 nothing the route should have been on
and as much credit as i give the jets
for hanging around and hanging around
even though they wouldn't have scored
more than 23 points if they had played
20 quarters last night much less four
the browns never delivered the death
blow until that long touchdown pass from
baker mayfield to odell beckham uh yeah
before that it just felt like sluggish
and it's there and the but the browns
need to deliver that death blow earlier
in the game and just put these teams
away and not have baker mayfield out on
the field with two minutes left in the
game get these guys off the field win
these games big they have the talent to
do that to win the games big get the
guys off the field and wait for the next
game yeah i i i don't disagree by the
way what sorry go ahead peter i i was
gonna say what happened to the 200 000
watch
that story sort of died a slow death did
he
i didn't notice i'm wearing the watch
he had a he had a watch on where the
watch right he had a watch on before the
game that apparently was even more
expensive than the one from last week
one of only 12 a 2.5 million dollar
watch but look i'm sure behind the
scenes they told him you're not wearing
the watch you can't wear the watch and
they told him during the game you can't
wear the the gold tinted visor and they
he wasn't on the field for that key
third down play after his one-handed
catch because the officials made him
exit the field and get that shield off
of there of course he was upset about
that after the game he said other guys
have been allowed to wear that shield
i'd like to know who because i think
this is a pretty clear rule that unless
you've got a medical uh authorization
you can only wear the approved visors so
uh you know look he wants to be
different that's fine when he plays like
he did last night guys i don't care what
watch he wears i don't care what advisor
he wears he's one of the most exciting
players in all of football don't you
agree peter yeah
of course he is he's a fantastic
football player uh it's just that
there's always a sideshow
uh and and that's one of the things that
to me is maddening about him
but obviously he's a great player when
he's healthy
he's one of the 10 most dangerous
players at any position in football you
know he's the patrick mahomes of
receivers
but but again i mean i agree with what
you said mike this is a team
that is better than 19 points better
than a team playing a third string
quarterback most of the game
uh and look i'll hand it to the jets
defense they showed up last night
but i will also say that you know i
think there's enough in that game that
freddie kitchens goes back to cleveland
and says we need to work on on things
and especially the offensive line
um i think the jets defensive front
really found some leaks uh in that in
that cleveland offensive line but again
look cleveland is always we've always
thought they were going to be a work in
progress this year i thought it was a
good but not great game against a
against an outman team
yeah i mean hey it's it's it wasn't
perfect no and you know what i mean hey
we saw tom brady and the new england
patriots up by 43 playing in the fourth
quarter you know these teams you know
they're gonna stay in there late in the
fourth quarter because they got to get
their team in shape for four quarter
football too and next week they expect
to play fourth quarter football against
the los angeles rams who are coming into
town for sunday night football on nbc
i'd like to add but either way um no
this is the other thing that jumps out
to me and i think peter you bring up a
great point about the offensive line
protection i'll say to that hey it's two
weeks in a row they've played defensive
coordinators who are very creative with
things they do at the line of scrimmage
and you can tell
defensive coordinators are trying to
test baker mayfield a second year
quarterback who hasn't seen every
defense in the world quite yet so
they're trying to see whether he can
figure it all out at the line of
scrimmage
will he panic in the pocket and think
he's got pressure when he doesn't have
pressure i thought that was the thing i
enjoyed seeing the improvement from the
cleveland browns last night even though
it wasn't perfect they stayed patient
with the run a little bit the protection
was definitely better than last week and
baker mayfield was not as fooled as many
times as he was last week last week
there was a few times it was a three-man
rush and everybody was at the line of
scrimmage and he thought he was like hot
or getting blitzed and he wasn't he was
running out of the pocket and throwing
the ball and there was nobody around him
so a good start and let's not forget
their defense is pretty damn good
that's another thing we got to give a
little credit to and steve wilkes and
what he's brought to the table so
they're a work in progress but there's a
lot of talent here and at least think
the arrow is going up for right now
here's a little more from baker mayfield
after the game last night when he was
asked where he needs to improve in order
to take his game to the proverbial next
level
i think i need to be better uh checking
the ball down uh getting completions you
know i said it last week after watching
that tape it's completions getting the
ball in our guy's hands and
just putting us in good position you
know keeping the chains moving keeping
the positivity rolling
you know the interception last night was
a situation where he had nick chubb they
pointed this out very well on the
broadcast wide open nick chubb 15 yards
short of where baker mayfield threw the
ball but he decided to force the ball to
the guy who was covered for the bigger
play ball gets popped up in the air ball
gets picked off and if the jets had any
semblance of an offense that's kind of
the moment that could have been a
turning point in the game you're not
going to get away with that when you're
playing the rams because the rams can
take the ball down the field after that
turnover and turn it into points that is
definitely why baker mayfield has to be
looking for the open guy even if it
isn't the big play that he wants to make
peter
yeah and look this is the maturation of
a young quarterback all young
quarterbacks the other day i was talking
to josh allen after the bills game and
one of the things that i said to him how
are you better this year and he said i'm
not taking the chances that i took down
field last year he said i i will
i will be
more patient than i was last year and
each and he told me about a couple of
throws
in the game on sunday that a year ago he
thought he would have tried to make
that on sunday he looked shallower and
he looked safer
that is what bruce arians and byron
leftwich are trying to get uh jameis
winston to do i mean it's crazy you're
still doing that in year five but those
are the kind of things that is how a
young quarterback matures and chris i
know that you have to know this
that when you first come into the league
you have to think oh i can make that
throw you know you're interviewed before
the draft and hey can you make all the
throws oh yeah i can make all the throws
well sometimes it isn't smart to try to
make all the throws no exactly right
it's not it's what we love about baker
mayfield because he does have that brett
favre mentality and he always wants to
push the ball but yes peter you're right
you got to break yourself out of college
habits you know in college it was just
easy oh gosh i'm protected and we're
just we're the oklahoma sooners and we
just are a machine and we move the ball
down the field and every time i drop
back to pass it's 15 and 20 yards and
he's still adjusting on the fly here to
life in the nfl where guys aren't always
as wide open and sometimes checking the
ball down is the right thing and
sometimes having to punt the ball after
third down is the right thing to do too
because you know what the defense is
they got nfl players over there too and
they're getting paid a lot of money as
well so it's all a learning process
you're exactly right and it's all going
in the right direction i think it was a
good good start for a team to get a win
they had a lot of pressure on them
they're they're under the microscope and
uh i'm kind of excited for this
cleveland team i i am i don't think
they're going to be overwhelmed by the
spotlight that's the one thing now
whether they play well we'll see but i
don't think they're scared of the
pressure and the scrutiny they're under
as far as all of us expecting fireworks
every week
i want to make one last point before we
take our first break miles garrett was
unstoppable last night for much of the
game but he's racking up the roughing
the passer penalties he's going to rack
up more and more fines and we always
think of this from the perspective of a
defensive back who is headhunting and
eventually has to worry about a
suspension they will not sit back and
let this guy tee off on quarterbacks all
year long they will find him and they
will find him and the fines will get
larger and larger and at some point the
conversation we're going to be having on
a monday is was this the roughing the
passer penalty that results in miles
garrett being put on the sideline for a
full game that never happens with pass
rushers it happens with defensive backs
but it's something we need to keep an
eye on because he had two last night he
had one last week and he'll definitely
be fined this week for the hits that he
had
on the jets quarterbacks last
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports